i'm real i'm realizing from this [ __ ]
conversation you like your [ __ ] milfs
yeah you like your harems i need my
spice man i i i i've spiced too
i like my spice yeah what did you find a
spice
find spice gum okay so like okay so like
aside from vanilla which we can all
agree yeah always always great
or always a solid but like i i i don't
want just like the normal kind of
relationship there always needs to be
like a twist to it you know
like what i like is like especially if
it's like a relationship where they know
they shouldn't [ __ ]
that that's like hot yeah there's a hot
yeah and it's just what you're like
that's why i like to mess with you guys
literally i like my
life you like danger [ __ ] yeah yeah
you're like flaming like tire mountain
fox right like
where it's just like this is just this
is just burning down to the ground but
i'm enjoying it
isn't that why like stepmom porn is so
popular because it's supposed to be like
forbidden yeah it's like taboo yeah yeah
right you know i think that's why it is
so popular because it's like oh i
shouldn't be well
it's it's like stepmom stepmom form and
like incest porn yeah yeah and it's like
it's you know it's like
even in the premise it's not i guess
technically incest it's just really
uncomfortable yeah yeah i'm surprised
aside from like mother's no breast there
is
none of us in recommended like any like
brother or sister hentai
that's because brother and sister is
like for some reason stepmom and kid is
like all right
but brother and sister is like oh oh
yeah also there's like
way too much problems i'm the opposite
but that's probably because i'm an only
child
so i'm just like brother and sister yeah
i wouldn't know
that's that's the bit too [ __ ]
realistic because get that out of my
head
assumption is like anyone who likes like
stepmom is like i mean you want to [ __ ]
your mind
it's like no no not [ __ ] all quite
the opposite i just don't know why it's
that
because it's like what is more forbidden
than doing that
and it's like it's like the most illegal
you can get whilst being legal
right
by every single measurable thing it is
[ __ ] up and wrong yeah yeah but not
really
yeah not really right like it only just
gets more
morally wrong right yeah the only thing
worse than [ __ ] your stepmom is just
step dad right
so it's you know it's it's
it's [ __ ] right but it's like because
it's like the way i judge it is that
it's the kind of pawn that you can't
really like or a scenario that if you
let's say you had sex with your
stepmother that's not the kind of thing
you can go you know so guys
totally legal by the way yeah but i did
sleep with my stepmother everyone would
not everyone would be yeah
yeah yeah like what off okay question to
you then
okay if mother's no breast was like if
the mum was a blood-related mum
no would you still be able to not do
that yeah no too realistic too realistic
that's two that's true like i have a mom
but a stepmom never had that can't
experience it yeah but you know i mean
not that i would want that anyway but
it's like what's the other one with
there's another hentai where like it's
like a russian mom
comes what it's like a russian blonde
woman comes to like 20 year old high
school neat and
it's like four episodes where they're
like [ __ ] new [ __ ] and it's good it's
the same i don't watch a lot of the same
[ __ ]
it's honestly the same [ __ ] but like the
guy's super into it
it's the same thing but this time the
mom is rushing yeah basically yeah
basically
um i don't know like it's like for some
reason it's weird right
i get it monkey brain but like story and
video games nah premise and porn
yes please yeah because because the
thing is like a lot of the hentai that
like i enjoy is like i said the ones
with spiciness and they just it just
happens that
a lot of them just happen to have
[ __ ] step incest in there and
like what i hate is when it's just like
the [ __ ] incest hentai when it's when
the brother and the sister they wanna
[ __ ] you know that's like such [ __ ]
that's like a big turn off for me you
know what i mean right that's like the
ones that make you like stand up and go
like oh [ __ ]
oh god the hard tap the hard time
what is this when is the [ __ ] hentai
you know you know the [ __ ] ones i
mean the unichan hentais that's like
instant softy get the [ __ ] out of my
face there's so many people into that
though
because it isn't i think overflow right
is that one of the most popular hints
yeah this
this year yeah top three i think yeah
yeah and that is just all brother and
sister yeah and like i watched it
because i was like it's number three
yeah well surely the critics know their
stuff right surely
first episode like brother in the bath
and then sister comes in the bath okay
all right all right jesus
just accidentally [ __ ] inserts and
it's like for [ __ ]
sake what did i expect what do i expect
which how do you accidentally
insert you know how does that happen
speaking of accidentally insert what was
the [ __ ] short form
like hence i thought you're gonna oh i i
got i can't remember the name
it was the one it was like the girl
falling from the second the girlfriend
in the second floor
i'd like because the reason i watched
that one was it was because it's like a
full season right yeah
and this was this was a hentai that
somehow ended up on [ __ ] annie chart
in my anime list
no there's there's there's sometimes
like overflow yeah that was like a
seasonal anime that ended up on my anime
list
for some reason right because it's it's
like five minute episodes and it's like
a full season so the full season is like
what is important
yeah but it's poor so i don't know how
it ends up on on seasonal anime lists
but so i like species reviewers yeah all
right
so yeah i'd um i can't remember the name
so it's like [ __ ] google the name
yeah i forgot what it was but basically
the premise is like
there's a guy who's living in like a
really old like rickety apartment that's
like kind of falling apart
and there's a girl on that lives right
above him like a really hot girl
and the girl was like doing dance
practice or whatever the [ __ ] it was and
because the apartment is so rickety and
old
she falls through the second floor like
like thing yeah it goes down to the guy
where the guy is sleeping
and she lands on his dick
and inserts and i'm like and you can
also see that her underwear has somehow
shifted
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which for one
the [ __ ] logistics
the [ __ ] physics that goes into this
one because he must have like just had a
permanent stiffy
for what like like a correct angle at
the correct
it was like a [ __ ] angle-perfect
frame perfect
fall you know what i mean like so we're
gonna do the second floor clip uh the
penis needs to be angle perfect
the fall needs to be frame perfect for
the landing to go smoothly
but the reason the reason i find it so
hilarious was because it was on a
seasonal anime show right and
it got fancy and whoever was fan
stopping this oh yeah it was funny
whoever has found something with this
was obviously not like taking this
seriously
because you know he was technically
still translating it but
the [ __ ] phrasing that he used was
there's literally a frame where the girl
says shoot your goo my dude
i'm just like this is [ __ ] awesome
that was very good
yeah i just i just wanted to bring that
one out because i thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious